[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
the silence of the lambs first arrived
in american theaters over 30 years ago
on february 14
1991 since then it's one of only
three films to win the top five
categories at the oscars
best picture best actor best actress
best director and best screenplay this
week we're joined by angelica jade
bastian
critic at vulture to talk about the
film's legacy
now there's a new show about clarice
hannibal had his
own show for three seasons what do you
think keeps drawing people back to these
characters
i think one of the most fascinating
things about their dynamic is it brings
up issues of gender and power
and class especially and i think that
mix of things
really entices people but also
hannibal lecter is not like a lot of
other serial killers we see in pop
culture
a big part of who he is deals with a
sort of class fantasy because of
how exalted his taste is and how refined
he is and how
even though he's obviously a serial
killer he has
his own weird moral compass and so you
can almost
get what's going on and you can kind of
like tap into that even though you're
like yeah he's a serial killer but man
that food actually looks
good um
[Laughter]
and also it does though it does
but also for me like uh one of the
reasons i'm probably so enticed by the
story
is that it has echoes of the blue beard
fairy tale which is probably one of my
favorite fairy tales
and plays on gender and power can you
tell us a
tiny bit about that oh of course it's
like one of my favorite things to talk
about but uh the bluebeard fairy tale
um in essence is about a very young
woman who
marries a rich older man
and is a french fairy tale and he's had
many many wives who've
kind of disappeared mysteriously when
they get married he
gives gives her the run of the house and
says you
have the whole house except for this one
room and of course she looks in the room
and it has all his dead wives so the
thing is with
the blue beard fairy tale it brings up
really interesting ideas about gender
power death desire all of which exists
within silence of the lambs
well like um beauty and the beast kind
of like that
yeah beauty and the beast i mean i'm
sorry for going for like an easy one
at disney don't go into the west wing
sort of thing
sorry i mean it does have those vibes i
mean a lot of
you know it's a fairy tale that echoes
throughout so much of
western storytelling sure yeah yeah
so how responsible do you think silence
of the lambs is
for people's fascination and pop culture
with serial killers
so i think definitely silence of the
lambs was a huge
influence on the flux of serial killer
movies we ended up seeing throughout the
90s and early arts
um i think that it definitely sparked
something in hollywood
and audiences but i think american
audiences for better or for worse have
long been interested in true crime and
serial killers
we're kind of obsessed yeah i think it's
weird i'm not into
it i'm i find it both fascinating and
repulsive
there you go i think that's what most
people feel right yeah
all right and interesting yeah so
for people that like the dynamic between
clarisse and hannibal
what other characters in films would you
recommend like what other films would
you recommend that have that sort of
dynamic
so the first thing that pops into my
mind is this really great 1987
neo-noir uh called black widow that
uh follows deborah winger as a detective
who's hunting
this con woman's slash killer femme
fatale played by theresa russell
and it brings up a lot of these same
dynamics we see in silence of the lambs
which came out a few years after that
but it's two women so
the dynamics are a little different and
it's very rich and really fascinating so
sansa lambs was the last film to win
all five of the top five oscar awards is
there another film that you think
deserve
deserves that distinction ah questions
like this always crack me up i'm gonna
be
absolutely a hundred with you i am like
the worst critic to ask that question
because you couldn't pay me and i do get
paid for this
to give a damn about the oscars i
don't believe in what they represent
although yes there's definitely films
i've loved who've been
you know the handmaiden the favorite
those would be
like really that would be amazing to see
them win a bunch of
oscars but that doesn't happen but alas
oscars kind of suck in my opinion all
right
fair enough uh so now let's say that
you're in charge
of a reboot of silence of the lambs or
just the entire series
you can cast hannibal and you can't cast
clarice who do you pick
okay you're gonna like want to set me a
flame for this answer but like
i'm s i sort of don't want them to be
rebooted anymore
like we've had such definitive
performances especially like
you have anthony hopkins who i think
really embodies how i imagine the
character but then you also have mine
it's mickelson
giving a completely different
performance from the
the tv series hannibal which you know
has a very dedicated following and i can
see why
i'd rather people take inspiration from
the dynamics that exists within clarisse
and hannibal rather than rebooting them
again
give them a break and i'm talking about
that clary show
i don't know about that we'll see
someone
else just wants to do the accent that's
it's that sweet southern accent
i i guess that's a choice
all right angelic it's been great having
you where can people find you
you can obviously find me writing for
vulture as well as on twitter at
angelica bastian well austin thanks so
much for coming on the show
thank you for having me this was a lot
of fun
available to watch on demand is monster
hunter
track's end here it's definitely bravo
team they don't just disappear
behind our world there is another a
world of dangerous and powerful monsters
that rule their domain with deadly
ferocity when lieutenant artemus and her
loyal soldiers are transported from our
world to the new one
the unflappable lieutenant receives the
shock of her life
in a desperate battle for survival
against enormous enemies with incredible
powers and unstoppable terrifying
attacks artemis played by mila yovovich
teams up with a mysterious hunter played
by tony jaw who has found a way to fight
back
and available to watch on demand is
supernova if you had
one wish in the world what would it be
i wish this holiday wouldn't end
so can you tell that it's gotten worse
sam played by academy award winner colin
firth and tusker played by stanley tucci
are partners of 20 years traveling
across england and their old camper van
visiting friends
family and places from their past
following a life-changing diagnosis
their time together has become more
important than ever until secret plans
test their love like never before
alright well that's it for today but
leave us a comment and let us know what
you'll be watching this week
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]